[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien einen schönen guten Abend
ihnen allen heutes Champions League
Dienstag alles dazu gleich mit dir
Christina wir gucken nach Dortmund guten
Abend und wir blicken jetzt auf das was
wichtig ist und wird
immer mehr geflüchtete Städte und Kreise
schlagen Alarm der Bund kündigt weitere
Hilfen und schärfere Grenzkontrollen an
nach den russischen Raketenangriffen die
Ukraine meldet Probleme bei der
Energieversorgung
und Malerei trifft Mode Pablo Picasso
und Coco Chanel zwei künstlerseelen
begegnen sich in Madrid
[Musik]
wegen stark gestiegener
Flüchtlingszahlen auch wegen des
ukrainekrieges sind einige Kommunen und
Städte nur noch bedingt oder gar nicht
mehr aufnahmefähig und darum fordern sie
stärkere Unterstützung darum ging es
heute bei einem Gipfel zwischen Bund
Ländern und Kommunen schauen wir uns
jetzt gemeinsam die Ausgangslage an von
Jahresbeginn bis September haben fast
135.000 Menschen etwa aus Syrien oder
Afghanistan einen Erstantrag auf Asyl
gestellt das sind rund 35 Prozent mehr
als im Vorjahreszeitraum hinzu kommen
etwa eine Million geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine ein harter Kriegswinter dort
könnte die Zahl der Schutzsuchenden noch
steigen lassen über die Ergebnisse des
flüchtlingsgipfels Thomas Reichert sehr
angespannt sei die Situation sagt die
bundesinnenministerin und ihre
gipfelgäste aus Kommunen und Ländern
finden das auch neben Flüchtlingen aus
der Ukraine ist auch die Zahl der
asylanträgers anderen Ländern deutlich
gestiegen
dieser humanitäre Kraftakt ist immer
schwieriger zu bewältigen je länger
dieser furchtbare Krieg anhält
deshalb stehen wir als Bundesregierung
hier ganz eng an der Seite der Kommunen
die stark belastet sind und an die
Grenzen ihrer Kapazität kommen
finanzielle Zusagen macht Felser nicht
verspricht aber 56 weitere Gebäude des
Bundes für die Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen
in Kommunen wie hier in Schwerte in
Nordrhein-Westfalen werden bereits
wieder bürgerseele und Turnhallen zur
Notunterkünften umgebaut
wir haben uns ganz konkret von meiner
Stadt zu sagen zwei Zeltstädte repariert
in Dresden ist eine Messehalle gemietet
das heißt die Situation insgesamt der
geflüchteten Menschen hat eine
Größenordnung erreicht die sehr wohl
vergleichbar ist mit den Jahren 15 und
16 viele Flüchtlinge schlagen sich
aktuell von Serbien in die EU durch von
der serbischen Regierung fordert Fräser
daher die visumfreie Einreise aus
Drittstaaten zu stoppen die
Innenministerin will außerdem die
Kontrollen an der Grenze zu Österreich
verlängern das findet bayerns
Innenminister gut der verlangt aber auch
mehr Geld es ist wirklich dringend
notwendig dass ja der Bundeskanzler und
der Bundesfinanzminister
klare
Vereinbarungen dann auch mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten treffen diese neuen
Vereinbarungen soll es dann im November
geben
ja wie sich die Problematik vor Ort in
den Kommunen darstellt das schauen wir
uns jetzt an tatsächlich liegt es nicht
am mangelnden Willen geflüchtete
aufzunehmen sondern an der Tatsache das
schlicht und einfach Unterkünfte fehlen
bzw das Geld dafür gleichermaßen
schwierig ist das für Schutzsuchende und
Helfer wir uns Jutta sonnewald aus dem
Landkreis Bayreuth berichtet
hier finden geflüchtete Ablenkungen und
die Möglichkeit über ihre Sorgen und
Nöte zu sprechen im Integrationszentrum
im oberfränkischen Pegnitz treffen sich
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine und das
Afghanistan mit ehrenamtlichen Helfern
diesmal mit dabei Landrat Florian
Wiedemann er will das Beste für die
vielen Neuankömmlinge doch momentan
kommt er an seine Grenzen
wir hatten keine Plätze mehr verfügbar
und deswegen musste ich im Endeffekt
weil der Druck so zugenommen hat musste
ich letztlich die Turnhalle jetzt
aktivieren als Flüchtlingsunterkunft als
Notunterkunft diese drei Afghanen die
vor dem Taliban regime aus ihrer Heimat
geflohen sind leben derzeit in der
Pegnitzer Schulturnhalle gemeinsam mit
rund 50 anderen aus ihrer Heimat und aus
Syrien
wie kann Gott es ist schwer für uns wir
können keinen Deutschkurs besuchen
können nicht ins Fitnessstudio und wir
dürfen nicht arbeiten
ist vor sieben Monaten mit ihren Kindern
aus der Ukraine nach Deutschland
geflohen noch sind Sie privat
untergebracht doch sie suchen eine
eigene Wohnung das ist auch in Pegnitz
nicht einfach sie wäre bekommen Hilfe
von Jobcenter und
also die deutsche suchte welche Leute
schon Arbeit Susanne Bauer und ihr
ehrenamtlicher Unterstützerkreis greifen
den geflüchteten in Pegnitz schon seit
2015 unter die Arme sie wünscht sich für
ihre Kommune eine unbefristete Stelle
für Integrationshilfe dessen Personen
die sind damit ihre
ganzen Jacken ihre Persönlichkeit
einfach schaffen die Vertrauen und
schaffen sich da ihre Verbindungen und
sie verschwinden ja wieder wenn diese
Stellen limitiert sind und dann fängt
der nächste wieder von vorne an Florian
Wiedemann hat enorme Probleme für die
geflüchteten in seinem Landkreis schnell
geeigneten Wohnraum zu finden nun zieht
der Landrat in Erwägung solche Container
aufzubauen
und warum immer mehr Menschen aus der
Ukraine fliehen zeigt sich auch heute
wieder russische Angriffe wieder auch im
Westen also fernab der eigentlichen
Kampfgebiete im Osten und Süden gestern
waren durch russische Raketen in allen
Teilen des Landes mindestens 19 Menschen
getötet worden im Visier von Moskau ist
nicht zuletzt die Energieversorgung
konkret bedeutet das in Lemberg und
anderswo Strom ist kaum da die Sorge vor
kälteren Tagen umso mehr Alisa jung
berichtet aus der Ukraine wieder ein Tag
an dem sich die Menschen in der Ukraine
in Sicherheit bringen müssen russland
hat erneut mehrere Regionen beschossen
Kiew und Lemberg laut Bürgermeister
waren 30 Prozent der Stadt ohne Strom
dabei sind viele doch gerade noch dabei
die Schäden vom Kriegsbeginn zu
reparieren wie in irpin bevor Schnee und
Kälte kommen an Felina koordiniert die
Arbeiten an diesem Mehrfamilienhaus
wir werden es nicht schaffen in einem
Monat fertig zu sein bevor es kalt wird
leider es ist viel Arbeit die oberen
Geschosse sind alle kaputt
wie sie hier bald wieder leben und nicht
frieren sollen
illusorisch im Nachbarort nowo petrifzi
ist fast nichts kaputt die Sorge vor
einem kalten Winter ohne Strom trotzdem
da Segi hat sich vorbereitet baut eine
Mauer um die Terrasse zum Kälteschutz
und hat einen Generator gekauft
er funktioniert gestern nach dem Angriff
auf Kiew kam der gleich zum Einsatz
dann kamen alle Nachbarn zu mir um ihre
Telefone und Laptops zu laden
wir haben auf einem Gaskocher zusammen
gekocht richtig leckere Kartoffeln
um das Netz nach Angriffen auf
Infrastruktur stabil zu halten will der
Stromnetzbetreiber von Kiew kontrolliert
den Strom ein paar Stunden abschalten es
wird den Bewohnern von irpin nicht
helfen was Sie brauchen Frieden um ihr
zuhause vor dem Winter zu schützen
die massiven Raketenangriffe Russlands
ließen heute die G7 Staats- und
Regierungschefs zu einer virtuellen
Sondersitzung zusammenkommen
zugeschaltet war auch der ukrainische
Präsident silenski er forderte härtere
Sanktionen gegen Russland und Hilfe beim
Aufbau einer effektiven Luftabwehr die
sieben führenden Industrienationen
Verurteilten den russischen raketenbe
wahllose Angriffe auf Zivilisten seien
ein Kriegsverbrechen hieß es in einer
Erklärung nach dem Treffen
wir wollen Nachfragen bei Ulf Röller in
Brüssel Ulf welche Botschaft sendet
dieser Sondergipfel der G7
ich glaube dass der Sondergipfel mehrere
Botschaften hat einmal Solidarität der
ukrainische Präsident selensky hat noch
mal sehr klar die dramatische Lage
deutlich gemacht was eben dies
Raketenangriffe verursachen und dass er
Luftabwehrraketen dafür braucht die
Amerikaner haben ihm das schon
zugesichert weitere Länder könnten
folgen dann gab es eine Warnung der G7
an Putin dass er keine Atomwaffen
einsetzen sollte oder auch nicht auf die
Idee kommen sollte Infrastruktur von
NATO-Mitgliedstaaten anzugreifen das
würde mit äußerste harte beantwortet und
dann gab es noch eine schutzbotschaft
seitens der G7 man wird verstärkt in der
Ostsee Militärpräsenz zeigen um eben die
Infrastruktur und die Pipelines zu
schützen Fazit von diesem g7-gipfel man
sieht Putin auf einer absoluten
eskalationskurs und man will diesen
eskalationskurs mit äußerster Härte
beantworten danke nach Brüssel ulfreller
die Welt schaut weiter mit Bangen auf
die ukrainischen Atomkraftwerke vor
allem auf die größte Nuklearanlage
Europas in saporicia heute hat sich nun
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossy bei russlands
Präsident Putin für eine Schutzzone
eingesetzt ein Atomunfall sei eine
Gefahr nicht nur für die Region sondern
für die ganze Welt sagte der argentinia
Putin gab sich offen für einen Dialog es
sei aber gefährlich die Debatte über die
ukrainischen Anlagen zu politisieren
positiv hat sich Bundeskanzler Scholz
zum Vorschlag geäußert den eine
Expertenkommission zur gaspreisbremse
erarbeitet hat der Entwurf sei eine sehr
sehr gute Grundlage dass die Preise für
Unternehmen und Bürger bezahlbar blieben
dagegen forderte
CSU-Landesgruppenchef Dobrindt die
gaspreisbremse solle früher kommen wenn
sie im Frühjahr greife sei die
Heizperiode vorbei
noch mehr Uneinigkeit gibt es beim Thema
Atomkraft und zwar auch innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition der Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken sollte eigentlich längst
vom Kabinett beschlossen sein aber vor
allem zwischen Grünen und FDP knirscht
es die Liberalen verlangen den
Weiterbetrieb aller drei verbliebenen
AKW bis 2024 grünen Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck beharrt darauf nur zwei am Netz
zu lassen und das auch nur bis Frühjahr
23 Theo Koll in Berlin nach der Wahl
schlappe von Niedersachsen kündigte die
FDP eine Profilschärfung innerhalb der
Ampel an ist dieser AKW Streit auf
offener Bühne jetzt nur der Auftakt
nun zumindest sprach Christian Lindner
gestern im Plural von den Liberalen
Positionslichtern die jetzt angeschaltet
werden müssen das wäre dann mehr als nur
das akw-thema und in einer Koalition
bleibt es natürlich ein Nullsummenspiel
was der eine mehr beansprucht fehlt den
anderen also das würde mehr Streit
bedeuten beim heute noch einmal
verschärften Streit über den
Weiterbetrieb der AKW ist man sich nicht
einmal mehr einig ob man sich zuvor
jemals einig war die Grünen sagen es gab
eine feste Vereinbarung das zwei
Atomkraftwerke bis früher nächsten
Jahres weiterlaufen sollten und bei den
Liberalen wird es genauso vehement
bestritten Robert Habeck warnte heute
Isa 2 das Atomkraftwerk in Bayern müsse
jetzt runtergefahren werden damit es
dann repariert rechtzeitig fertig sei
für die kalten Monate für die FDP ist
auch das eine falsche Darstellung des
Resultat ist eine Art Kernspaltung auf
offener Bühne ich höre aber dass sich
die drei ampelchefs heute dazu diskret
getroffen haben allen dürfte die Gefahr
be sein denn wenn am Ende kein AKW
weiter betrieben wird ist auch in der
Ampel keinen geholfen Danke für die
Hintergründe nach Berlin Theo call dann
jetzt weiter mit einem düsteren Ausblick
des Internationalen Währungsfonds der
IWF senkt seine globale
Wachstumsprognose für kommendes Jahr auf
2,7% und warnt vor dem Risiko einer
globalen Rezession für Deutschland sagt
die Organisation sogar einen Rückgang
der Wirtschaftsleistung vorher um 0,3
Prozent und das hat auch mit hoher
Inflation zu tun hoch werden deshalb
auch die Lohnforderungen das hatten die
Gewerkschaften für den öffentlichen
Dienst schon angekündigt am Nachmittag
wurde es dann konkret
10,5 Prozent plus fordern Verdi und der
deutsche Beamtenbund für die zweieinhalb
Millionen Beschäftigten bei Bund und
Kommunen Anfang kommenden Jahres soll
dann verhandelt werden Hans-jürgen Piel
hat die Einzelheiten
ob Busfahrer Müllwerker Pflegekräfte
oder Erzieher für fast 2,5 Millionen
Beschäftigte im öffentlichen Dienst von
Bund und Kommunen fordern die
Gewerkschaften kräftige
Gehaltssteigerungen Ausgleich für hohe
Inflationsraten hinter den Beschäftigten
liegen bereits zwei Jahre des
reallohnverlustes und eine zu erwartende
Preissteigerung die signifikant auch für
das nächste Jahr ist und deshalb ist
unsere Forderung absolut realistisch
10,5% mehr Lohn und Gehalt fordern Sie
mindestens aber 500 Euro bei einer
tarifvertragslaufzeit von zwölf Monaten
die seit Jahren höchste Gehaltsforderung
in einer Tarifrunde des öffentlichen
Dienstes trifft jetzt allerdings auf
Kommunen deren Kassen ebenfalls durch
starken Preisauftrieb belastet sind in
einer Zeit wo wir nicht wissen wie sieht
die Wirtschaft morgen aus
appelliere ich ganz deutlich an die
Gewerkschaft mit uns gemeinsam in ein
intensiven Diskurs zu treten aber diese
überzogene Forderung
möglicherweise zu relativieren
Einmalzahlungen als Kompensation für
gestiegene Preise wie noch bei
Verhandlungen zu den entlastungspaketen
im Sommer diskutiert lehnten die
Arbeitnehmervertreter heute erneut ab
Einmalzahlung die sind für uns
verbrannte Erde wir haben sehr schlechte
Erfahrungen damit gemacht und das
angesichts der jetzt auch hinzukommenden
Dimension erhöhte Energiekosten etc
würde das wirklich tatsächlich verpuffen
bis Jahreswechsel gilt noch der alte
Tarifvertrag es könnte eine harte
Lohnrunde bevorstehen für Januar Februar
und März sind bereits Verhandlungen
vereinbart
Sturmtief Giulia hatte in Südamerika
bereits mehr als 30 Todesopfer gefordert
und auch in Mittelamerika gab es fast 30
Tote und massive Schäden als Hurrikan
war der Sturm am Sonntag in Nicaragua
auf Land getroffen dann zog er über
Honduras El Salvador und Guatemala die
Regenmassen führten zu Überschwemmungen
und Erdrutschen die zumeist in Armut
lebenden Menschen waren den
Naturgewalten weitestgehend schutzlos
ausgeliefert
er gilt als malergenie des 20
Jahrhunderts sie als die Frau die die
Modewelt geprägt hat Pablo Picasso und
Coco Chanel was weniger bekannt ist
beide bekannten und schätzten sich
arbeiteten sogar an gemeinsamen
Projekten und haben sich dabei
vielleicht auch gegenseitig beeinflusst
der These geht gerade ein Museum in
Madrid nach im Kern geht es ungefähr
darum wie viel Kubismus aller Picasso
steckt in den Kleidern von Chanel Anne
Ahrendt
eine Zeitreise 100 Jahre zurück zu zwei
Künstlern die neues wagten Pablo Picasso
und Coco Chanel
mir war wichtig dass die Kleider und die
Gemälde alle aus den 1920ern stammen
damit ein wahrhaftiger Dialog zwischen
den einzelnen Kunstwerken entstehen kann
das Museum Thyssen bornemissa in Madrid
setzt die Kreationen des Malers und der
Modedesignerin zusammen in Szene so
wirken etwa die beigen Töne und feinen
Striche des Kleides wie ein Spiegel
gleich in dem Gefieder der Taube in
diesem Stillleben
an Picasso faszinierte war seine
unerschöpfliche Kreativität und sie sah
das Picasso in der Lage war alles zu
verwandeln zu zerstören um neu zu
erschaffen zu zerlegen um neu aufzubauen
die beiden verkehrten in derselben Kunst
und Theaterszene Picassos erste Frau die
Balletttänzerin Olga kochlova liebte
Chanels Kleider ihre geraden kantigen
Schnitte zurückhaltende Farben grau
schwarz-weiß die Werke ähneln sich
repräsentieren den damaligen Zeitgeist
es ist waren die sogenannten goldenen
20er die Jahre der großen Freiheit der
großen Experimente aber auch der großen
Anspannung Malerei und Mode
avantgardistisch und zeitlos zugleich
bei Ausnahmekünstler im Zwiegespräch
hier gibt es sportlich weiter Christin
so langsam geht es bei der Champions
League in Richtung KO-Phase absolut in
der BVB ist hochmotiviert drei Tage nach
dem spektakulären Remy gegen die
bayern-peilt Borussia Dortmund mit einem
Sieg gegen den FC Sevilla den
vorzeitigen Achtelfinale Einzug an
allerdings darf dann auch Manchester
City in Kopenhagen nicht verlieren der
BVB will offensiv Auftreten mit Anthony
modeste 34 Jahre und dem halb so alten
yusufa mukoko kam die Wände gegen die
Bayern nach 0:2 am Ende 2:2 durch die
Tore der beiden eine Doppelspitze die
nicht immer erste Wahl für den Trainer
war
dass die beiden sehr gut harmonieren
nicht auf dem Platz nicht nur auf dem
Platz sondern auch neben dem Platz das
haben sie glaube ich auch eindrucksvoll
demonstriert am letzten Samstag und
ich kann mich wiederholen wir freuen uns
wenn beide treffen cute Bellingham 19
Jahre bvb-kapitän beim Hinspiel und der
herausragende Mann beim 4:1 Sieg der FC
Sevilla hat daraufhin den Trainer
gewechselt hoch ist St Pauli hat den 18
der La Liga in Spanien übernommen und
prompt gegen den Dritten einen Punkt
geholt dank ausgeklügelter Taktik sie
haben jetzt am Wochenende
unserer Meinung nach dreimal das System
verändert innerhalb des Spiels wir
müssen uns darauf verschiedene Dinge
konzentrieren und uns vorbereiten kein
Grund für den BVB das Selbstbewusstsein
vor Schreck in der Kabine zu lassen
und parallel zum BVB hofft auch RB
Leipzig mit Trainer Marco Rose auf ein
weiteres Erfolgserlebnis diesmal
auswärts beim schottischen Meister
Celtic Glasgow und alles zum vierten
champions-league-spieltag morgen Abend
im ZDF hier bei uns Sportstudio live
bei der judo-wm in Taschkent Usbekistan
haben die deutschen Frauen die zweite
Medaille verpasst Europameisterin Alina
Böhm unterlag in der Klasse bis 78 Kilo
im Kampf um Bronze der Polin Beater Paco
klotzko zuvor hatte sie im deutschen
Duell die Titelverteidigerin Anna Maria
Wagner ausgeschaltet
starke Frauen so viel von mir guck mal
Christian das ist auch gerade gekommen
eine Nachricht aus London nämlich das
König Charles III am 6 mai offiziell
gekrönt wird aber das auch noch
vermeldet von Katja horneffer erfahren
Sie gleich im Wetter dass es morgen noch
goldenen Oktober gibt was danach folgt
erklärt sie auch Christian Sievers
begrüßt sie später um 21:45 Uhr zum
heute-journal das gesamte 19 Uhr heute
Team bedankt sich wünscht noch einen
entspannten Abend und sagt bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend die Reste der Gewitter von
gestern zogen heute hier über
Süddeutschland hinweg auch im Norden gab
es einige Regenschauer der Nebel hier in
der Mitte Deutschlands aber löste sich
über Tag wunderschön auf und dann gab es
wieder viel Sonnenschein und die
Temperaturen erreicht Werte von 13 Grad
hier im Thüringer Wald und 20 Grad am
Bodensee in der Nacht wird es kalt
jedenfalls da wo es jetzt aktuell klar
ist da sinken die Temperaturen auf +3
bis -1 Grad out droht also verbreitet
Bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
Nacht am warmen Wasser bei 10 bis 8 Grad
und auch im Süden bei neun oder acht
Grad das liegt dort an den dichteren
Wolken aus denen in der Nacht auch noch
etwas Regen fällt sonst bildet sich
wieder dicker Nebel und mit dem haben
wir es auch morgen Vormittag erstmal zu
tun dann löste sich in der Mitte wieder
auf am ehesten stark bewölkt bleibt es
hier an der Ostseeküste und der Wind
dazu kommt aus südlichen Richtung etwas
anders sieht es auch hier im Alpenrand
aus da geht es auch dichtere noch etwas
Regen Bein Nordost wird die Temperaturen
morgen liegen ganz ähnlich wie heute
zwischen 14 Grad auf Rügen und 20 Grad
am Neckar oder auch am Oberrhein in den
nächsten Tagen geht das etwas
wechselhafter weiter an den Temperaturen
ändert sich vorerst aber wenig bei 13
bis 19 Grad guten Abend